[Musique]
connaissons depuis ce matin le prix des
tests de dépistage du coc vide dans une
semaine le 15 octobre vous le savez ne
seront plus gratuit le prix d'un pc air
sera de 44 euros pour les personnes
majeures non vaccinés et sans ordonnance
il ya 18 heures 20 ce soir
le peuple marseillais
ovationnent son ancien président l'heure
de lever toutes les mesures toutes les
contraintes n'est pas venu dans près
d'une trentaine de départements à
l'épidémie ne recule plus nous sommes
tombés à un niveau très bas mais ne
recule plus voir repart très légèrement
à la hausse je ne sais pas chambouler je
suis calme mais c'est aussi parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'expérience je sais pas
du tout ramolli je suis extrêmement sûre
non seulement de ma volonté d'être
président de la république mais même de
ma capacité à être élue présidente de la
république monsieur zemmour s'est
finalement présenté une copie qui soit
un peu moins de pâlotte que celle de
madame le pen mais c'est la même chose
et c'est là que l'extrême droite c'est
le rassemblement national d'ailleurs ils
voulaient dîné ensemble et vous savez
entre monsieur ménard monsieur zemmour
et madame le pen il n'y a pas une
feuille de papier à cigarette traiter
quelqu'un de négationnistes des
révisionnistes ça renvoie aux camps de
concentration
est-ce qu eric zemmour dit qui a pas eu
de camp de concentration non donc les
gens qui en poids ce vocabulaire là mais
c'est toute une partie de la gauche est
malheureusement de temps en temps des
journalistes aussi parle beaucoup d'eric
zemmour moi j'invite tout le monde à
écouter ce qu'il dit moi j'entends
beaucoup de propos haineux et j'entends
peu de propositions d et moore qui parle
de vous vous dupont-aignan me dit que je
devrai me lancer que je pourrais être
moins aussi candidat à la présidentielle
et vous ajouté si vous ajoutez zemmour
si tu es mieux placé que moi je
m'effacerai volontiers pour moi tu sais
l'important c'est qu'on gagne des
retraités qui observe tranquillement une
partie d'échecs sont appelés à respecter
les mesures sanitaires
[Musique]
l'avertissement vient de xavier un robot
patrouilleur sur quatre roues équipé de
7 caméras qui lui donne une vision à 360
degrés qu'est-ce qu'il a que vous n'avez
pas mais j'en sais rien aujourd'hui ne
m'intéresse pas elisabeth martichoux je
suis pas là pour parler de zemmour
maintenant je parle aux français
les images sont envoyées en flux continu
vers le centre de commandement et de
contrôle de la police qui peut
déclencher une intervention policière
luttons contre des refrains qui sont
amplifiées martelé que dis-je
obsessionnel puisque monsieur zemmour et
tous les jours à la télévision tous les
jours en matinale en midi nal en soirée
au milieu je suis le candidat de ce
qu'on appelait avant le rpr voilà pour
les plus jeunes ça veut rien dire mais
pour les plus anciens ça veut dire
quelque chose c'est à dire le
rassemblement de la droite populaire
bonapartiste gaulliste qui rassemble les
classes populaires et la bourgeoisie
patriotes j'y tiens beaucoup vous avez
dit si quelqu'un un jour est mieux placé
que moi je lui serrerai ma place est-ce
que ce jour est arrivé je suis pas
canal+ c'est dommage
c'est à vous madame
désormais vous êtes obligés d'en faire
des caisses pour montrer tout va bien
le cours n'ont presque pas de corde dans
la maison d'un portable de faire des
caisses
banon on voit pas trop justement on n'a
pas compris la réponse c'est le visage
d'un homme qui vient de réussir un
exploit unique au coeur de l'himalaya le
manaslu plus de 8000 mètres d'altitude
qu'il a gravi à la force des bras mehdi
mais s'il trouve et que la personne
n'est mieux placé tant mieux au
l'occurrence il avait samba trouver
maintenant je suis la candidate soutenue
par le rassemblement national choisi par
le rassemblement national je fais
campagne proust amena billet est un
russe de 29 ans amputé des deux jambes
une équipe de plusieurs sherpas
l'assister pour cette ascension est
aidée pour les passages les plus
délicats
c'est le but